So far, we've learned a little
bit about determining electron
configurations.
Let's see if we can use that
information to group elements
on the periodic table and then
guess as to what they might do
when they react with
other elements.
So let's just figure out the
electron configurations of a
couple of elements just for
a little bit of practice.
So, lithium, right there.
What does it look like?
Lithium's electron
configuration.
You get the first
shell, is 1s2.
Two electrons there.
And then you have 2s1.
And sometimes, just to be quick,
to get the notation, is
you can imagine lithium's
electron configuration is the
exact same thing as helium's
electron configuration-- this
is helium's electron
configuration-- plus the 2s1.
This could have also been
written as-- do that in light
blue-- could also have been
written as helium, 2s1.
Which essentially means that
lithium's electron
configuration is exactly what
you would have written for
helium's electron configuration,
and then you'd
have written 2s1.
You could do that a
bunch of times.
Let's say if we wanted to
figure out the electron
configuration of iron.
Instead of going through the
whole thing, you know, it's
1s2, and then it's
2s2, and 2p6.
Instead of doing that whole
thing, you could just say, OK,
iron has the same electron
configuration.
So you could say iron's electron
configuration is the
same thing as argon's electron
configuration.
So I'll just put argon
in brackets.
And then you get 4s2.
And then you have one, two,
three, four, five, six.
So d6.
And we learned that when you're
in the d subshell, or
when you're in the d-block of
the periodic table, you are
actually backfilling
the previous shell.
So when we're in the fourth
period, in the d-block, we're
backfilling the third shell.
So 3d6.
And someone had asked-- and
this is an interesting
question-- why does
it do that?
Why does it not just continue?
Why doesn't it fill the
fourth d shell?
And the way I think about it--
and this is all intuition, and
things at the atomic level
really start to become, on
some levels, non-intuitive-- but
the way I think about is
as the atom grows larger and
larger, there are more spaces
between the previous orbitals.
For example, this is just
how I visualize it.
If my first shell
looks like this.
Let's say the s looks
like this.
And then, if I just cut it out,
let's say the p's look
like something like this.
This is maybe the
second shell.
The p's look like this.
And then the next place an
electron might want to be
might be in the third
shell, right?
So the third shell would
be like this.
And then you fill out
the third p shell.
This is just an intuition.
This isn't exactly what an
electron would look like.
Maybe the third p shell would
look something like that.
Look something like that.
And then look something
like that.
And then you're in
the fourth shell.
So you're doing the
fourth shell.
The s subshell might look
something like that.
And then instead of immediately
starting the next
p shell, you're in
the d-block now.
So this is-- let me just
write some labels-- 4s.
This is 3s.
This is 3p.
This is 2p.
This is 2s.
And then 1s is inside of 2s.
So you don't have to worry
about that too much.
But my intuition behind why the
d orbital gets backfilled
is because now, as the atom gets
larger and larger, you
have these spaces in between
the previous orbital.
So now, after filling the 4s
subshell, or the 4s orbital--
so this is 4s here-- out here,
we go back and we fill in the
3d orbital.
So we're going back and
we're filling these
spaces right here.
So this is a lower energy
state than this.
It takes more energy to cram an
electron back into the 3d
shell, back there.
But then once you do that, now
you're ready to then go to the
4p shell, which might look
something like this.
So an electron would rather go
to another shell, which is the
fourth shell, rather than
backfill the 3d shells.
But once it fills out the fourth
shell, it fills in
those spaces in between.
And as the electron gets bigger
and bigger, there's
more and more spaces
in between.
So eventually, when the electron
gets big enough,
there's going to be spaces
between the d shells, and
that's where the d orbitals
and that's where the f
orbitals will go.
That's my intuition behind
its working.
And obviously, when we're
dealing at the atomic scale,
as far as I'm concerned, that's
the best that I can do.
But fair enough.
That's not what I want to do
here, but that was a good
question, as to why do you go
and backfill the third shell
when we're in the
fourth period?
Fair enough.
This is an easy way to write
iron's electron configuration.
The reason why I'm doing all of
this is to figure out how
many electrons you have in
the outermost shell.
In the case of lithium, you
have one electron in your
outermost shell, right?
This is your outermost
shell right here.
You have one electron.
And you could have done the
same thing right there.
In the case of iron, how
many electrons in
the outermost shell?
Remember, the outermost shell
is the period you're in.
And this is the outermost
shell.
So even though these are higher
energy electrons-- it
took more energy to backfill
those into the lower energy
shell-- it's these that are on
the outside energy shell, the
fourth shell, that are
going to be the
ones that are reacting.
And how many are there?
There are two.
And this is an important
thing.
So there's two here.
There's two on the outside
shell here.
And actually, there's going to
be two for any of these in
pink right here.
Any of the ones in the d-block,
what happens?
You fill whatever period
you're in.
Let's say that you're
in period five here.
Right?
You're going to have 5s1.
5s2.
And then you're going to go back
and you're going to fill
the 4d shell.
Right?
But in terms of how many
electrons you have on the
outside shell, in this case the
fifth shell, you are going
to have two electrons.
So all of these are going to
have to electrons in their
outermost shell.
In the case of these, the
outermost electrons are going
to be 4s2, right?
Because then you go back and
fill the 3d, but the outer
ones are 4s2.
So this one also has
two electrons in
its outermost shell.
How many does this group have?
And I've just used a word that
I don't know if I've defined
before, but the group are the
columns in the periodic table.
And as you can see, they all
have patterns to them.
Everything in this first group
has one electron in its
outermost shell.
If you don't believe me,
look at hydrogen.
Hydrogen's electron
configuration is 1s1.
Its outermost shell is 1s.
It has one electron there.
Right?
And that's true for
all of these.
All of these guys have
two electrons in
their outermost shell.
These guys have those
same two electrons.
We can view it that way, in
their outermost shell, but
then they go and backfill
the d shell.
But in terms of their outermost
shell, only two electrons.
Than once you fill the d-block,
or you go backfill,
in the case of the fourth
period, you go and backfill
the third d sub-orbital.
Then you go back to filling
the fourth shell again.
Now the p block, right?
So this one's going to
have three electrons
in its outside orbital.
Or you could say three
valence electrons.
This is four, five, six,
seven, and eight.
Let me do one more, just in
case you don't believe me.
What's the electron
configuration for Sn.
This is, what, selenium?
I'm not even sure.
But let's say Sn.
What's the electron
configuration?
It's going to have
the same electron
configuration as krypton.
Yes, that element is krypton.
There is such an element.
So it will have the
same electron
configuration as krypton.
So I could have figured
out krypton's electron
configuration just by going
through the whole periodic
table, but this is just a
faster way of doing it.
Same thing as krypton,
and then it has 5s2.
Then it goes back and backfills
the d-block.
So then there's 10 there.
So 4d10.
And then it starts filling
up the p-block in
the fifth shell again.
So 5p2.
So how many valence electrons
does it have?
Valence electrons,
or electrons in
the outermost shell?
Well, what's the outermost
shell?
It's the fifth shell.
So these and these.
These electrons have a higher
energy state than that.
It took a little bit more energy
to cram them back into
that previous shell than
it took to put
these on the s orbital.
But if you talk about the
electrons that will react, and
that's why I'm emphasizing
these, these are the electrons
that are going to react with
other atoms. Or sometimes with
just other electrons, even.
This one has four outside
electrons.
And you see that right there.
Four outside electrons.
And since the outside electrons,
for the most part,
are the ones that you're going
to care about, there's a-- I
guess you could say, a notation
where you only draw
the outermost electrons.
So, let's say, for hydrogen, you
could write it like this.
Where you're only drawing the
outermost, valence electrons.
Valence electrons are just
the outermost electrons.
You could write it like that.
But this says, hey, I just
have one outside
electron for hydrogen.
If I wanted to draw
it for iron?
Iron, right here?
How would I do that?
I have two electrons in my
outermost shell, so iron I
could just do like this.
And electrons, they
tend to be paired.
So if I have, let's say I wanted
to take the example of,
if this is Sn, this
is selenium.
Let me do carbon.
Carbon, I have four electrons
in my outermost shell.
So carbon I could
write like this.
Or if I didn't want to pair
them, in theory I could write
them like that as well.
And now they're ready to react
with other things.
Now what does this tell me
about, you know, this one has
one electron in its
outermost shell.
These blue, these noble gases--
and we'll talk a
little bit about them in a
second-- have eight electrons
in the outermost shell.
How does that help me when I'm
actually trying to figure out
how things react?
Well, it turns out that all
atoms want to have eight
electrons in their
outermost shell.
And that number is important.
Eight.
They want to have eight
electrons in
their outermost shell.
This is the most stable
configuration for atoms. Or I
guess you could say, to some
degree, a better energy state
for the atom.
And why is it the
number eight?
Well, that's something
to think about.
This is another fundamental
number that
just pops out of nature.
And I've thought a little
bit about it.
It must be something about the
atoms in the outermost shell,
when you have eight, they
resonate well with each other.
And they somehow don't get
in the way of each other.
Or don't want to push away
from each other.
I don't know the
answer to that.
And frankly, if someone could
really answer the question of
why eight, exactly why eight,
they would make a good career
for themselves in physics
or chemistry.
But through experimentation, it
has been well established
that atoms want to have
eight electrons in
their outermost shell.
So the question is, if you're
dealing with something like,
let's say you're dealing
with potassium.
Right?
Potassium has one electron
in its outermost shell.
Let's say you have stuff like
chlorine, that has seven
electrons in its outermost
shell.
What do you think's going to
happen if you put some
potassium near some chlorine?
What's going to happen?
Well, what's the easiest
way for the chlorine
to get eight electrons?
Well it has seven in its
outermost shell.
What's the easiest way?
Well, it'll want to gain an
electron really, really badly.
And what's the easiest way for
potassium to have eight
electrons in its outermost
shell?
Well, if it lost that one
electron, then it will have
eight electrons in its outermost
shell, right?
Its outermost shell won't be
the fourth shell anymore.
It'll be the third shell.
But it'll have eight electrons
in the third shell.
Its configuration will then look
like argon if it loses
that one electron.
So it'll be a more
stable state.
So if you put sodium in the
presence of chlorine, what's
going to happen?
This electron wants to jump off
of sodium real bad so that
sodium can have eight electrons
in its outermost
shell, or have an electron
configuration like argon.
And that electron is going to
jump to chlorine, and then
chlorine will have eight
electrons in its outermost
shell, and also have
an electron
configuration like argon.
And so, as you can imagine, this
group right here, which
are called the alkali metals.
And we'll talk probably
in the next video why
they're called metals.
This group here,
alkali metals.
And they tend to exclude
hydrogen, and
we'll talk about that.
These really want to give
away electrons.
And because of that, they're
highly, highly reactive,
especially if you put them
in the presence of these
elements, these yellow elements
right here, which are
called the halogens.
These really, really want to
take electrons from other
things, because they just need
one to get to eight.
They usually want to give away
electrons, because they just
have to give away one
to get to eight.
And the reason why hydrogen,
actually, isn't included is
because hydrogen doesn't want
to give away its electron as
bad as these guys.
This rule that your outermost
shell wants to get to eight,
that's true for everything
except for
hydrogen and helium.
Hydrogen and helium, just
because they have one shell,
they're happy with just
two electrons.
And so with hydrogen, sure, it
could lose an electron, but
could just as easily gain an
electron and be happy, because
it'll have a full first shell.
But all of these other ones,
these alkali metals, they want
to give away electrons
really bad.
When people in chemistry talk
about metallic nature, they're
really talking about how
badly something wants
to give away electrons.
Anyway, I'm all out
of time now.
In the next video, we'll
continue discussing the groups
in the periodic tables
and any trends we can
ascertain from them.